hello my name is vikram dendi coming to
you from the heart of microsoft research
building 99 at our redmond campus
welcome to day two of the health and
life sciences tracks of the microsoft
research summit
this year we have invited summit
participants to join us in envisioning
strategies that focus on two
interrelated types of impact health
discovery and health delivery
there has never been a more critical
time to build a healthy global society
the kovid 19 pandemic has highlighted
the growing need for technology that
supports accessible healthcare
one of our aims at microsoft research is
to help ensure that every person on the
planet can live to their physical and
mental potential
we believe this needs to happen by
advancing inclusive and equitable
technologies supporting the health of
populations and individuals making
healthcare easy to access across all
communities
in recent years we have witnessed
incredible progress in advancing science
and technology for improving human
health
but
the benefits of these advancements are
unevenly distributed throughout society
and more work is needed
this is why it's an exciting time to be
a part of the research and technology
community
as we have a unique opportunity to
transform the fields of health and life
sciences
as you saw yesterday in the health
discovery track
leaders in research and the industry are
driving the acceleration of data and
compute driven methodology for
diagnostic and therapeutic innovation
this research is laying the groundwork
for early diagnosis and accessible
treatments
treatments that respond to urgent needs
quickly and equitably
as someone who has supported microsoft
teams in establishing new pipelines from
research to incubation to scale over the
last decade i especially enjoyed nobar
afeyan and micros and blatt's
perspectives on creating repeatable
models for conceiving resourcing and
building new ventures
ventures that invest in breakthrough
technologies
you also heard about the potential ways
in which artificial intelligence and
machine learning can be applied to
positively transform the practice of
medicine and the delivery of care
today in the health delivery track
you'll learn about research and
technological advancements we are
working on
together with researchers scientists and
industry leaders around the globe
our collective goal is to make health
care more accessible so that no matter
where you are
essential health care is at your
fingertips
improve equity in health care so that
all individuals get quality health care
they need
and strengthen resilient communities
through modern technologies and
innovations enabling them to thrive
the potential for positively
transforming the practice of medicine
and the delivery of care has become a
galvanizing force for cross lab cross
boundary collaboration here at microsoft
research and we hope that you are
inspired by the diverse voices that
you'll hear today
let's talk about a few highlights you
won't want to miss today
in the first half you'll hear from
leaders who are pioneering new models to
advance health equity access and
resilience in partnership with
communities
you'll also see a series of lightning
talks showcasing collaboration networks
focusing on research and innovation
and the next generation of research
talent
in the second half you'll hear from
leaders who are envisioning new
strategies for combating disparities in
specific disease areas like
cardiovascular treatment
you also won't want to miss a demo
on new tools that translate real world
data into real world evidence
thank you for joining us
before we dive into the first panel
let's check in with my friend and
colleague chris white who leads mission
oriented research and software
development teams in our special
projects group